merci la parole est à présent à Monsieur
Roger carucci pour le groupe UMP oui oui
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je pense que dans tous les
groupes et tous les élus ont
naturellement été extrêmement marqué par
l'accident de brettini marqué aussi il
faut le dire quand c'est bien par la
responsabilité la transparence du
président de la
SNCF mais monsieur le ministre vous avez
fait et c'est logique en période de 10
budgétaire vous avez fait des choix
d'investissement alors je suis pas cet
après-midi là pour poser une question
là-dessus on peut dire d'accord pas
d'accord pour l'abandon de tel ou tel
ligne en réalité nous avons et depuis
longtemps un système ferroviaire où pour
faire soyons direct du TGV on n pas mis
beaucoup de moyens sur le reste dans le
cas de l'Île-de-France on a même fait
mieux entre 1980 et 2000 on a pris
l'amortissement du matériel roulant en
en île-de-fance pour le mettre sur le
TGV et on l'a pas remis sur
l'île-de-fance donc tout ça et là
sincèrement quel que soit les
gouvernements gauche droite tout le
monde a fait ça et la SNCF faisait ça
aujourd'hui nous sommes en face d'une
situation où dans toute la France en Île
de France comme dans toute la France des
lignes sont usées alors j'entends bien
j'ai entendu le président de RFF dire il
y a aucun problème le fait que le
système soit très ancien ou usé ne
présente aucun risque aucune difficulté
pardon de vous dire que je ne crois
guerre cela je pense que
l'usure finit par présenter des risques
et en tout cas des inconvénients majeurs
pour ceux qui sont transportés retard
annulation panne se multiplie il y a pas
seulement les accidents graves il y a
aussi le problème constant en
île-de-fance comme dans toute la France
des retards et des difficultés pour tous
les voyageurs mais monsieur le ministre
il avait été évoqué en île-de-fance et
dans toute la France un plan d'urgence
sur l'entretien sur ce qu'on appelait
les points noirs les points noirs
c'étaaiit les aiguillages les plus
anciens c'était les systèmes les plus
difficiles c'était les lignes que même
les associations d'usagers appellent
eux-mêmes les lignes poubelles je parle
pas du matériel je parle bien des lignes
ne serait-il pas temps monsieur le
ministre de définir dans le cadre du
budget que vous évoquez sur l'entretien
d'avoir un plan d'urgence sur les points
noirs du système ferroviaire pour faire
en sorte au moins que tous les éléments
tous les lieux de vrai danger soient
réglés très vite au-delà de l'entretien
normal de l'ensemble des lignes merci
Monsieur Frédéric
huviler merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Sénateur carci précisément
les propos que je viens de tenir en
relais de ceux du monsieur le Premier
ministre soulligne ce que vous constatez
d'ailleurs c'est-à-dire les M faits ou
les carences d'une politique antérieure
qui a été menée qui est est celle de la
concentration je reprends vos propos de
financement sur des grands ouvrages de
type LGV non que les grandes
infrastructure ne soit pas nécessaire
elles le sont mais de lancer un rythme
qui est un rythme un
rythme qui était bien supérieur à nos
capacités a fait que nous n'avions pas
et vous n'aviez pas les la possibilité
de financer dans le même temps le réseau
existant le RFF dès notre prise de
fonction j'ai demandé à RFF de pouvoir
mobiliser un plan d'urgence c'est
précisément les 2 milillards 5
supplémentaires qui s'additionneront aux
2 milliards de modernisation d'entretien
du réseau c'est-à-dire que là où il y
avait un budget d'un mliard 4 sous les
précédentes années nous sommes à 5,5
milliards annuels de modernisation du
réseau classique c'est vrai également
dans le cadre de l'Île-de-France où
demain le Premier ministre avec le
président de de la région nous Cécile
Duflot et moi assisterons à la signature
de l'engagement financier sur le plan de
mobilisation qui en marge du nouveau
Grand Paris permettra de d'engager 7
milliards de travaux de régularité et
d'amélioration du du réseau c'est
important de pouvoir répondre sur ces
questions d'entretien non qu'il faille
faire confusion entre entretien et
sécurité bien évidemment s'il y avait
des lignes qui posaient des problèmes de
sécurité ell seraiit fermé où bien
évidemment les mesures sont prises
lorsque certaines situations amènent à
ce que des des la sécurité soit mise en
cause notamment l'abaissement du seuil
de vitesse c'est assez régulier donc
lorsque nous parlons et je le dis parce
qu'il faut être précis sur la
terminologie lorsque nous parlons de
lign malades il s'agit bien de lign
sensies sur la régularité sur le fait
comme vous l'indiquez vous-même
lorsceque vous parlez de problème de
sécurité vous invoquez des retards des
annulations ou des pannes en
l'occurrence ce ne sont ont pas des
critères de sécurité mais bien de
dysfonctionnement du réseau matériel
roulant qui sera renouvelé ou de
l'infrastructure lmême qui est
vieillissante et parfois vétuste mais de
ce point de vue il est important de bien
signaler que nous sommes sur les réseaux
ferroviaires français parmi les pays les
plus sécurisés et avec une
infrastructure qui est les plus sûres
d'Europe pour autant j'ai demandé au
mois de mars dernier à l'établissement
public de sécurité ferroviaire de bien
vouloir me rendre un rapport je ne
savais pas que l'actualité nous
amènerait à nous en entretenir ainsi
dans cette situation mais de faire un
point précis des problèmes de sécurité
et d'organisation de la sécurité
ferroviaire ce rapport me sera rendu cet
automne et nous pourrons adapter les
mesures nécessaires pour être au
rendez-vous de ces enjeux qui sont des
enjeux indépendamment de nos convictions
des enjeux de territoire et de la
population